madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse ça me donne la
première ministre madame la Première
ministre comme l'écrivait Euripide le
temps révèle tout et n'attend pas d'être
interrogé en effet les années passent et
le scandale de la prévision de la
privatisation pardon des conso
d'autoroute révèlent des entrailles est
toujours plus nausées à bond du système
oligarchique qui pile les Français les
mois passent et plus rien ne justifie
votre refus obstiné de reprendre le
contrôle des prix des péages et des
équipements qui devraient appartenir aux
Français les jours passent et
s'enchaînent les révélations
consternantes sur la compromission du
personnel politique français avec ceux
qui se gavent sur le dos des Français le
magazine Marianne a révélé madame la
Première ministre que le secrétariat
général du gouvernement aurait dissimulé
par un faux l'indigence des documents de
travail qui vous ont permis de négocier
un accord en 2015 avec les
concessionnaires d'autoroute vous étiez
alors madame borne directrice de cabinet
de Ségolène Royal et vous avez établi
avec l'ombre des modèles Macron Alexis
Kohler un accord scandaleux qui a offert
9 milliards d'euros au concessionnaire
privé d'autoroute dans la société
Eiffage or
oh madame borne vous avez dirigé la
branche des concessions d'autoroute pour
Eiffage entre 2007 et 2008 ça vous fait
rire pas moi comment avez-vous pu mené
de telles négociations alors que vous
étiez en confident d'intérêt évident à
la tête de ses concessions madame borne
comment pouviez-vous ignorer les
bénéfices intolérables que fac faisait
sur les péages pourquoi n'avez-vous rien
fait pour établir la justice ni comme
directrice de cabinet ni comme ministre
ni comme première ministre pire encore
alors que vous étiez ministre des
Transports vous avez attribué la
conception de la 79 un contrat juteux de
500 millions d'euros avec une concession
de 48 ans garantissant un rendement
juteux de 5 à 10% qui a obtenu cette
concession Eiffage qui peut croire
encore à votre impartialité aussi ma
question est simple êtes vos services
des Français ou des phases
je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur Clément bonne
ministre chargé des transports
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Tanguy dans le sillage de ce qu'a dit la
première ministre au service de
l'intérêt général je voudrais avoir un
mot en particulier pour si vous le
permettez Stéphane testaud agent des
routes qui est décédé hier je suis allé
voir ses collègues hier après-midi
me permettait en tant que ministre les
transports d'avoir une pensée aussi pour
les agents des routes qui rendent
service et aux Français mais je vois que
ça ne vous intéresse pas mais je vais
répondre à votre question mais c'est
Tanguy
je vois que je vois que je vois que vous
et votre démagogie vous portez bien et
je vais vous dire Monsieur Tanguy j'en
ai assez j'en ai ras-le-bol de votre
démagogie au service de votre démarque
de votre électoralisme insupportable et
se complotisme de base étage qui salit
nos agents publics vous venez de parler
du secrétariat général du gouvernement
qui est sous l'autorité de la première
ministre qui est composé de
fonctionnaires dévoué je ne supporterai
pas que vous jetiez le soupçon sur le
secrétariat général du Gouvernement je
ne supporterai pas que vous jetiez le
soupçon sur l'administration du
ministère des Transports comme vous
l'avez fait sur l'administration du
ministère de l'Économie à chaque fois
que nous avons été sollicités je l'ai
fait encore la semaine dernière nous
avons répondu nous avons répondu à
chacune de vos demandes nous avons
transmis le rapport de l'Inspection
générale des finances j'ai transmis
moi-même la semaine dernière j'ai
transmis moi-même la semaine dernière à
la demande de parlementaire et de
journalistes une note de 2013 sur ce
sujet il n'y a pas lieu d'avoir le
moindre complotisme on peut avoir un
débat politique j'ai été des heures dans
cette émission vous étiez là d'ailleurs
monsieur Tanguy pour répondre à chacune
de vos questions sur les concessions
pour répondre à chacune de vos questions
sur les péages mais cessons ces mots
insupportables qui participent aussi à
cette violence politique nous ne pouvons
pas vivre dans ce climat je vous demande
d'arrêter ce complotisme odieux
parle si tu as des mots plus forts que
les silences ou garde le silence il
ajoutait le silence est un aveu
merci
[Applaudissements]
Tanguy vous n'écoutez même pas les
réponses vous lisez des fiches préparées
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre